natürlich sind fast alle grenzen
geschlossen das gilt auch für die
dänisch deutschen grenze und genau dort
haben sich vor zwei jahren eine
85-jährige denen und ein 89 jähriger
deutscher in einander verliebt und
seitdem verbringen sie eigentlich jeden
tag zusammen in dänemark das ist jetzt
aufgrund der korona maßnahmen nicht mehr
möglich für das paar aber kein grund
keine zeit miteinander zu verbringen
stattdessen treffen sie sich jetzt jeden
mittag wir sehen gerade in diesen
bildern am grenzzaun zum gemeinsamen
mittag wir haben einmal mit dem paar
gesprochen
wir sitzen wir hier am täglichen tag
vorm um 35
wir hatten zwei meter abstand wird davon
wir umarmen
und darum sind wir so weit voneinander
zu früh da haben wir uns im haus
genommen modells und geliebt und werden
es kennt weiß dass ich mich noch mal 89
so verlieben kann
und seitdem fritten mehr 2008 für jeden
tag sonntags natürlich kommen ab 12 sie
kann gut kochen und dann kriegen wir
hier mir dass wir haben noch mehr
gekriegt und das bleibt ja so lange und
deshalb habe ich auch handschuhe an